welcome back to another amazing episode
of off the record with the careful boys
today we got Steve Hey Stephen
oh it's Red Bull time already
no middle name for me Stephen Paul Green
yeah I'm in trouble you guys have middle
names what's your middle name I don't
have a middle name yeah
read it read that out loud because I
can't dude your last name's kind of a
middle name
Anthony Lily my last name is kind of a
first name what yeah it is true all
right next is Nicholas
all right so it is in it I don't do you
know what it means you write it out I
might be able to read it I can't write
that [ __ ] out all right it's the end of
the year guys it is the end of the year
it's gonna be [ __ ] December hopefully
before
it's a it's Bert or board Alfred quad
it's Herman really not on the moon
because at the end of the year let's
talk about let's recap let's talk about
some of our favorite moments and
favorite videos and favorite stories
from this past year would you rather
[ __ ] would you rather [ __ ] your mommy
the classic how did that happen
yeah how did that happen I don't
remember who was the first it probably
came out of this guy's mouth I think it
was Joe no we were I remember we were
[ __ ] around off camera acting like we
were gonna say that we're trying to find
a prompt yeah and then it started
rolling it was this guy he was the one
that ass
yeah you asked off camera you were
sitting right there yeah you asked off
camera and then we decided to flip it
and ask you on camera and then you got
all nervous you were like
it was supposed to be an OTR but it only
bit it was a 10 minute video that's
classic us okay this is Anthony's my
stage name yeah look at my off camera
stuff is obviously different that's why
in the video you were like you didn't
want to answer it we're like you're the
one who thought of it I don't know if I
thought of it I think you guys are
twisting history right here we got
[ __ ] tape we could watch we go do the
tape don't count off cameras where it's
fun dude my favorite one My Fit one of
my favorite episodes for sure was
Anthony Lee's in 911 tonight
he wasn't even here right it was not
even here to defend himself
and they can make you believe it never
happened man dude I heard Dicky laughing
in the other room I hear Nikki laughing
I'm like what I'm like what what's so
funny and she's like Anthony leaves like
a 911 to die
she saw the clip on uh and he dances to
express that I do love the cliffs
because I get reminded of the stuff that
we shot he doesn't always shoot a video
there's a lot of like Little Golden
moments that's kind of embedded in the
overall story and I kind of forget the
moments that happen but when you see it
pop up like oh yeah that one's so good
because I'm all I'm thinking is what's
his reaction to seeing this because he
didn't even know what he said now we get
to finally see it because look at his
face right now that's all we want that's
what we work so hard for I'm not trying
to answer some class action lawsuit with
a bunch of people but from people that
were like actually hurt by 9 11 is all
so so you think it was real that this is
new stuff so this is different because I
guess the recording button is on yeah
yeah you can't be sued for art though
he just said he's a different Anthony
off camera too we got him dead to right
yeah we got you dude it's all been a
setup that's all we got you you're going
down you son of a [ __ ]
I will say not being here and then
seeing a whole [ __ ] social media clip
to talk about your [ __ ] hardcore at
911 denier is a unique Human Experience
does that make you feel loved in any way
yeah like man the guys like me man they
talk about me when I'm like oh yeah
weird way yeah when Bobby Hunters was
here we're all just taking Church
dunking on you and your company and just
your existence
those files were lost when Steve told
Bobby hundreds hey you ever heard of the
air sesh and he's like no and then Steve
goes I think these guys are kind of
biting your style I think I think
they're ripping off your design there's
this guy named Anthony Lee he's a shoe
cobbler
so you sure you don't want to be here on
the 17th well you're not gonna be here
this is dangerous okay first of all I
said let's recap the years let's not
recap every moment you're a big part of
the show though dude oh dude remember
when Anthony opened up to us about how
he loves fidget Trucking whoa
[Laughter]
and he's like what about you guys you
guys like some weird [ __ ] and then we're
like yeah
first of all I like eating water okay
the context the context we were talking
about I think Ryan was hosted and he was
like what's everybody's guilty pleasure
or something [ __ ] like that and
everybody's like oh my cold tomorrow
yeah he's like uh I like eating
watermelon we're like how the [ __ ] do
you feel to the point where I'm sick and
I have acid reflux that's disgusting
he's opening up to you everyone no that
was a stupid [ __ ] everybody's guilty
pleasure was not literally the weakest
[ __ ] I ever heard in my life but you
said you like the [ __ ] memes on on uh
Instagram I just said iPhone it's funny
so do millions of people there's a
reason why that shit's popular and
there's a reason why you're wrapping up
on my [ __ ] no it's not about backing
me up it's about saying your guys's
guilty pleasure sucked that's all I'm
saying and it's not like you liked it
like 30 years ago like you like it now
when it's safe shut up what are some
other Anthony favorites of this year no
no let's let's generalize and broaden
this video talk Anthony is a gift that
keeps on giving Which video is going to
win the streaming award all the ones
you're in Anthony it's like you're
opening a present and then you got
another present
like a Russian doll of presents
there's another Anthony no no no no more
Anthony moments so many what about
guests wise are there any guests that
you guys really like that we should
bring back next year dude
it was a really funny moment yeah I
think I think there's a funny moment
where Anthony you like made a joke or
something or about you were talking to
Colleen and you were like oh yeah your
dad's a subscriber she goes my dad's
dead
[Laughter]
hey what's going on over here man
but that moment was funny because it
like it flew by so fast and she played
into it too yeah I mean she's really
like cool like that but Anthony didn't
know yet so he was like he's a [ __ ]
Hiroshima shadow
where'd Anthony gosh
that was a good answer yes what are some
of your favorite guests this year that
haven't been on before
um I do like some of the real estate
mortgage guys
[Laughter]
here we go
here we go
they're really tight you learn a lot
from those Bart's like yeah my mom time
traveler but I'm having my real estate
guy
my mom knows someone who's in the dark
arts my mom knows doctor strange but my
mom's got the voice of Chinese Jesus in
here but here's my Gardener yeah yeah
yeah I can't blame them I want to I
Really you guys have to go meet her you
guys have to do let's do the next JK
Adventure we'll get up I'll rent a car
I'll go pick her up dude what if we
treat it like it's like we're seeing a
spectacle at the circus she's not gonna
come out no of course we want to do this
no we all gotta Play Straight you don't
think we're respectful here with six
dudes at our house okay we get we all
get a group reading bro we play it
straight JK Adventure we get a group
reading from your mom's homies and at
the very would that be tight I'm kind of
curious what if you guys need to
actually need help and then she might be
like I'll come out and help what if we
all need help I got hella issues bro
we'll have we'll have some something
that we want help with and we'll bring
her in here we're like Show's dying we
need help yeah how do we fix the show
yeah oh that's good at that she can help
in like medical stuff okay well
when you drink sugar yeah I drink a lot
of if I drink sugar I get I get this I
get slam I get dry scalpish I could talk
about how my dick don't get hard that's
really good that's important you might
be able to help with that because I can
help in other ways and then we won't
even ask her if she wants to [ __ ] her
mom or dad like maybe maybe not even one
time yeah not even maybe dude I love
when uh when you ask Jake Tran who if
he'd rather [ __ ] his mom or dad and then
he said Mom and then Bart goes oh you're
not a butt guy
and then and then I I made that reel and
I posted it and I added him as a I
requested him as a collaborator and he
messaged back and said bro I can't put
that on my page
for a second I was just like hey man
like you know you ever you know and he's
like you know I've been around some
darkness and Bart's like did the
darkness ever touch you and the best
part of that clip is Ryan's face going
dude
I watched that like three times a day
oh [ __ ] and then like I was like I wanna
oh man
that was the face it's so funny but I
don't know if it's appropriate today's
video is brought to you by audible so
now I've been doing these long flights
from Hawaii to LA and that's about a
good five six hours and so I pretty much
watched all the movies that I could have
watched I did all the games and now I'm
going down to thankfully audiobooks and
with audible I could get one new title
for every month and what's really really
awesome right now I'm listening to this
book called Ready fire aim it's pretty
cool it's about the different stages in
businesses that get you to making a
hundred mil because wow at this point
I've done a few businesses that made a
couple hundred thousand some even hit a
million but then like to surpass this
level I don't know anybody in my circle
I don't even know how to get there and
what separates the companies from small
to big and so now I'm like listening and
I'm like this is so wonderful and I'm
like wow this is much more of a
sophisticated way to see business than I
ever imagined and that's what's cool
about audiobooks is you get access to
all these genius Minds some top level
folks and people that I might not have
any access to in my real personal life
but through the book I can and sometimes
I retain the information better when the
author tells me versus what I'm reading
because sometimes when I read stuff I
don't even remember what I just read a
sentence ago but when someone's telling
it to me because it's in their own words
it's like someone telling me a story me
too so audible is awesome they have
audio books they got podcasts they got
their own Originals it's a all One-Stop
shop for your audio entertainment so go
check it out let audible help you
discover new ways to laugh Be Inspired
or be entertained new members can try it
for free for 30 days visit audible.com
off the Record or text off the Record to
500-500 that's audible.com off the
Record or text off the Record to
500-500 to try Audible for free for 30
days audible.com off the Record yeah and
he [ __ ] rolled and then he's like oh
touched a family already goes
yeah he became all like heartfelt it's
just his reaction was just like it's
like when the joke can hit but it can't
stick dude bark did that to me too when
I talked about how this guy put hands on
me one time when I fell asleep at his
house and then yeah Bart was like did it
feel good
are you sure yeah I remember I remember
the whole room was quiet because we was
like we're like what the [ __ ] that's
when I was like oh these are my people
because you could you could like really
zoom in on that moment and take and like
I didn't want to change the energy the
room or anything and then Bart like
lightened it up right away and I was
like oh it's so funny yeah it's the
quickest way to heal sounds like fiction
I would have asked you're the your
verbal neosporins
because we're all kind of thinking it
because everyone's supposed to go oh I
can't believe that happened totally you
know I get it politeness blah blah but I
prefer that I prefer that
that's where I came up like I came up
around [ __ ] like that yeah I love that
[ __ ] it's the best yeah
people always take that [ __ ] we we
seriously for you and I'm like oh you
don't need to do this for me I'm good
we're a [ __ ] comedy show dude what
the [ __ ] you know what's funny um and I
don't remember any of these things but
the ACT outs and movies that we come up
with this year it's all like the movie
scripts we've made oh yeah or hyper
Bible plane yeah yo buying a plane yeah
yeah to sell some drugs yeah the heist
ones or the highest yeah everyone's high
schools that's like [ __ ] like the roles
that we have just showing people showing
people old enough for kisses is like my
favorite dude that was crazy the way you
you propped that up that's my favorite
thing that was great and the debut of
this jersey oh yeah a lot of these a lot
of great just the fact that people
people are always like why why is this a
thing yeah wait so have you seen that
movie before did someone do that I'd
never seen the movie before I'd seen the
clip all on the internet over the years
so I I just knew the clip but then I
knew it was a Clint Eastwood movie
obviously because but that clip isn't
well I guess like it's not like two
girls one cup because a lot of people
just don't know I've never seen that
clip I saw it on like a lot of very not
two girls one cup yeah hey but if it
goes viral I think we get credited but
it's the same shock Factor because
you're like whoa I didn't see that
coming I I think it's a different level
of a shotgun you're definitely mortified
when you see it I know what you mean
though what's your name more mortified
with oh I've never seen two girls one
cup oh let's show them right now let's
show them oh I'm not pulling up on my
laptop
bro
don't look away my dick's hard already
bro you can't show me this world it
might be something you like you might
like it
don't look right now don't look right
now just wait dude this is not it dude
no no hold on hold on wait don't just
wait don't spoil it for yourself don't
look over until it's time I never like
chocolate ice cream before this dude I
don't like poop oh [ __ ] did I get a
virus
[Applause]
there's a lot of girls here now dude
that's just pornography here we go let
me let me look it up where do I go go
Incognito dude
we're good we're good he's completely
safe he's safe dude
it went straight to [ __ ] sex selector
oh there's hot grannies in your area oh
Jesus Christ Bert's the guy who quits on
all the ads yeah stop clicking the
pop-ups
what's happening it's [ __ ] crazy is
that coming out or in yeah uh this is
for Nick all right Nick dude seriously
yeah dude now my phone got a virus dude
and then you have to rate it on a tent
and then you have to rate it out of ten
dude how did you get it so fast full
screen bro the music
[Music]
coming in
video
that's open it's almost done it's almost
done look it's almost oh no
video playing while he's like
that's two girls one cup dude
bro that was [ __ ] up yeah that's
really [ __ ] up the diarrhea that came
out of her butt went crazy you're
supposed to watch it as a 19 year old
yeah
dude
it was really dry I was about to say Yak
bro for my gag reflex is not that and
all you got Steve over here go it's the
same space throw up
oh no bro my stomach is like you can't
unsee that nowadays no yeah that one's
that one stays with you yeah that's I
remember some of the scenes I thought
this was a JK [ __ ] best moment where
we talk about our favorite we just made
a moment we just created we're trying to
create new ptsds you could make that a
short somebody just keep cutting to a
kid just video always I'm telling you
guys that's gold yeah that's [ __ ]
gold That's How we'll edit it for only
you [ __ ] would somehow be able to
compare two girls one cup to kids I was
trying to watch when the wallpaper came
up I was trying to watch it but like I
really when they started throwing up I
was throwing like I was dry heaving that
was Next Level oh my God I forgot that
they ate the [ __ ] and threw the [ __ ] up
oh they did that with a straight face
spoiler alert so basically to Bart's
earlier statement this versus old enough
for kisses same shock factor it's pretty
soft anyway
yeah they're both gross in their own
ways but I think it's very shocking has
a point do you agree oh yeah you know
what BART does have
like you [ __ ] look at this [ __ ]
[ __ ] I think we did a follow-up
on JK news about the two girls one cup
girl that she tried to have a life after
this and then yes Steve did it it was a
fake [ __ ] story wasn't it
that's what happened
I probably made it up she's trying to
have a life
how dare she try to have a life huh I
don't know if it was me dude it might
have been me I think it was you yeah was
it you yeah it was me it was a fake
article oh yeah I remember that wow yeah
I want to do a video of like what are
they where are they now dude that'd be
very important follow-up for all the 19
year olds out there for the rest of the
day you're gonna be a little [ __ ] up
man can you rate that video out of 10.
10 being what's your metrics 10's like a
great video like the best video like you
probably shouldn't give tens out because
it's like that's so hard to attain yeah
yeah but like you know yeah one being
it's really bad you should give ones out
unless it's like really a one really
really bad I give it like a like a like
a five out of ten dude five out of ten
jeez you seen worse no I just mean like
like it was fun to have like everyone
like oh my God seeing the reaction
um the production quality was pretty
good yeah um the shots they got in there
they saw everything I wanted to see is
that one of the most appalling things
you've seen that was the most appalling
thing oh that's number one for that I've
never seen anything crazy I don't know
anyone that shits as much as her dude
that was a big [ __ ] I thought that they
pumped her ass with fake [ __ ] and then
they [ __ ] it back out because it looked
the poo poo looked too perfect Too
Perfect yeah nah that should look like
straight dookie my boy
um pumped the fake [ __ ] in won't they do
that though in pornography don't they
like not but [ __ ] but they oh mother
like that in a porta potty really yeah
like perfect smooth and brown like that
not a lot of fiber there was no
discoloration it was just one solid
color yeah sometimes that happens she
probably two gallons of [ __ ] ice
cream the night before the throwing up
it was crazy dad I didn't think they
could I didn't think they could hide in
there and the music that matches too
it's so I don't know how'd you find it
so fast I Googled two girls one cup
I did two I got three viruses he was
taking forever he had a he had a pop-up
blocker on your phone it's impossible
probably yeah to close all those tabs so
hopefully we get a streaming for this
video now huh I mean we're you know
fingers crossed as usual we're nervous I
think I think that's the whole thing
that's going on where people reacted to
girls one cup and they're getting like
millions of views JK reacts to Two Girls
One Cup yeah we shot this video in 2006
and uh you guys are seeing it now it's a
Rebrand dude wait people are doing that
again yeah wow because there's a lot of
there's a whole generation that don't
know that makes sense though because
like we saw in 2006 and those people are
like 20 years old yeah they're like yeah
bro that was crazy [ __ ] yeah I feel like
Shell Shocked a little bit I think I'm
gonna skip lunch day though for real
that shouldn't be my stuff why don't you
take a Honda show Tiff dude she would
punch me in the [ __ ] face are you
skipping lunch so you can have dessert
uh soft serve chocolate but we were
gonna have we were gonna have beef
stroganoff no dude have you ever seen
meat Spinners I've seen Meats that's
nothing compared to this that's true
that's [ __ ] amateur hour do you wish
do you wish that you said just like
threw it away and said oh I saw two
girls in one cup yeah like like all you
guys
I like all you guys I should have been
so different you know like a [ __ ]
loser and that's what I guess that's
what I get and the fact that he was also
telling us I made it a point not to
watch it it is like oh well you're
[ __ ] oh I do now yeah I did say that
I set myself up that's why you know kids
out there are watching like just make
sure you conform always dude
foreign